more than one in three people over the
age of 65 is single and free to mingle
Meg Oliver hit the dating scene to see
how older Americans are searching and
finding love Meg good morning that's
right good morning Tony you might be
surprised to learn that the youngest and
oldest Americans are the most likely to
be single in America and many of them
are ready to mingle I spoke with some
mature singles to find out why it's
never too late to find love
how do you get back on the dating scene
when you are over 50 or even over 60. no
luck but I had 15 scammers I've been
dating online for the last year and a
half it's a popular question burning up
Tick Tock from mature singles how and
where can they find love the dating app
thing is just not for me I'm old school
table number 11 raise your hands Gail
Adams is old school too the 64 year old
created seven and Heaven singles a
dating service that hosts in-person
activities for people of all ages to
find romance it was my little side gig
and then in 2008 I lost my job so I made
my side job my full-time job and so even
in the recession dating is Big Business
absolutely they came recession and all
singles want love there are more than 27
million singles over 60 since 2013
online dating for this age group has
doubled a lot of younger people might
think senior citizens they don't really
have a lot of dates or sex what's it
like out there oh no they're they're
definitely they're my biggest
um numbers on this night on Long Island
24 people between the ages of 50 and 65
showed up for a night of speed dating we
popped in to see if Cupid's arrow might
strike how do you feel about tonight
tonight I'm looking forward to it it's
not like when you were 20 years old you
went into a bar girls all over guys all
over yeah you met somebody so why did
you come here why didn't I well my
husband passed about seven years ago and
as I was a 49 year old Widow I am now in
the dating scene why do you think there
are so many single older people now I
think this generation which is my
generation is the generation that said
if I'm not in a happy marriage I'm
leaving my mother's generation my
father's generation they were taught you
stay together you know and they did Stay
Together dinner a little late tonight
dear patience Papa had straighten up my
dressing table and today's world looks a
little less Ward and June Cleaver
between 1990 and 2015 the divorce rate
among older adults more than doubled and
researchers say there are many factors
including a sharp rise in women entering
the labor market that allowed wives to
afford divorce I think if I couldn't
afford to get divorced I wouldn't have
gotten divorced Susan Rosenthal a 72
year old litigator in New York City has
been dating for 20 years are you still
hopeful you'll find love I wouldn't be
doing this if I wasn't hopeful and I
love meeting people these days that's
mostly online what's the biggest
difference dating today versus before
you're first married when I started
dating in my 40s
there was a lot more game playing my
mother said you reach an age and you
don't really care what other people
think and I have reached that age so I
can be true to myself but some of the
trials and tribulations of dating among
mature adults might feel more familiar
to a younger age group Freddie Velasquez
says they get ghosted too presently the
Girl I'm dating
happened to go and take care of her
mother and we haven't spoken in a while
but why is it so important to have love
in your life I think that's important in
anybody's life you know to have that
moment
and you can sit down and be happy to be
with the one that's compatible with you
talks to you laugh with you you're
looking for that moment yes I and I'm
not going to give up on that moment
and according to gal Adams he has good
reason to hold on to hope and how many
matches have you made oh lots lots some
have stuck some have not stuck some come
back again is it ever too late to find
love no I got remarried at age 62. I've
had couples on my events that have met
and in the 70s that have gotten married
what's your advice to mature singles who
are maybe ready just to give up don't
give up I mean because you don't you
just don't know what's around the corner
but if you just let it go and just want
it it'll come to you it really will
and it came to Gail she met her new
husband through one of her events so
she's happily married and at the speed
dating event we went to every single
person except one picked a match oh hey
that's great yeah in person good odds I
don't want people to miss the name of
Gail's company with seven in heaven yes
ring a bell yes I like when you're in
Middle School ah what is it seven and
Heaven There was a kid's game you know
it's kind of like spin the bottle Seven
Minutes in Heaven they called it yeah
yeah I like Freddy's thing don't give up
it's never too late I definitely
definitely believe that and Freddie to
spent a decade taking care of a sick mom
made it very hard for him to find dating
so let's fingers crossed for Friday
because he really wants to find it so
Freddie I said hey okay